tiangong 1 ist abgestürzt der abschlag
wie zuvor vermutet in unbewohntem gebiet
im pazifik doch im erdorbit lauer noch
ganz andere risiken die weitaus
gefährlicher sind wieder absturz ablief
ob es gefährlich hätte werden können und
wo die großen gefahren durch
weltraumschrott drohen jetzt den klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja das war das etwas unrühmliche ende
der ersten chinesischen raumstation
vollkommen unkontrolliert stürzte sie
auf die erde mit dem risiko menschen zu
verletzen und größeren schaden
anzurichten um 2 uhr 15 stürzte die
unbemannte raumstation in der nähe von
tahiti in den pazifik vorab hatte die
chinesische raumfahrtbehörde noch
mitgeteilt dass tiangong 1 vor der
brasilianischen millionenmetropole sao
paulo in den atlantik stürzen würde also
immerhin nahe einer millionenstadt also
nicht ganz ungefährlich dabei verfehlte
sie point nemo also jetzt im pazifik an
ihrem absturz ort den dortigen friedhof
für raumschiffe raumstationen und
satelliten nur knapp dort werden
ausgediente raum fahrzeuge kontrolliert
zum absturz gebracht
die stelle ist jeweils rund 2600
kilometer vom nächsten stück land
entfernt und das ist wirklich ein
riesiger abstand wenn man sich vorstellt
dass die raumstation iss in rund 400
kilometern höhe um die erde kreist
deswegen ist point nemo übrigens auch
als pazifischer pohl der
unzulänglichkeit bekannt etwa zwei
wochen braucht man um dorthin mit dem
schiff zu kommen und natürlich auch
wieder zwei wochen um zurück zu gelangen
das risiko dass ein trümmerteil auf land
einschlägt dass gezielt support nemo
gesteuert wurde
ist also nahezu null die gefahr dass
hier irgendjemand geschädigt wird
absolut minimal point nemo wurde
übrigens mit hilfe eines
computerprogramms entdeckt und zwar im
jahr 1992 von dem kroatischen
vermessungstechniker rivoli luca tel
den namen hat dieser ort allerdings
nicht vom fisch nemo aus dem
zeichentrickfilm sondern verdankt in
einer romanfiguren zwar captain nemo aus
20.000 meilen unter dem meer von jules
verne an dieser stelle im ozean vermutet
man nur wenig leben denn der wind kann
nur wenige nährstoffen tragen da das
nächste land so weit entfernt liegt
starke meeresströmung halten
nährstoffreiches wasser außerdem ab also
wirklich der ideale ort um alles zu
begraben was man nicht mehr braucht laut
nasa ist dies vor allem für größere
objekte eben wir aus stationen und
raumfahrzeuge die sich in einer
niedrigen umlaufbahn befinden eine gute
möglichkeit denn bei ihnen besteht die
gefahr dass sie eben
nicht vollständig verbrennen bevor sie
den erdboden erreichen solche
raumschiffe und satelliten werden dann
kontrolliert am point nemo zum absturz
gebracht es gibt schätzungen nach denen
hier mehr als 260 raumfahrzeuge beerdigt
worden sind und die zahl ist in den
letzten jahren gewaltig gestiegen unter
anderem ich sehe auch die 142 tonnen
schwere raumstation die russische
raumstation mir 'nen begraben
eigentlich sollen dort alle
raumfahrzeuge landen die nicht mehr
genutzt werden aber bei den rang eines
haben die chinesen 2016 die kontrolle
verloren ist bliebe nichts anderes übrig
als dem absturz zuzusehen für die
raumfahrtagenturen weltweit war es damit
aber die gelegenheit ein objekt über so
lange zeit zu verfolgen und ihre
tracking systeme zu schicken
beim absturz ist die raumstation laut
chinesischer raumfahrtbehörde cms
größtenteils verglüht so dass nur noch
wenige teile dort abgestürzt sind vorab
wurde geschätzt dass es teile mit einem
gesamtgewicht von 1,5 bis 3,5 tonnen
sein würden dabei ist der absturz eines
satelliten oder raumschiffes eigentlich
etwas positives denn dann kann es oben
im erd orbit keinen schaden mehr
anrichten denn die unzähligen anderen
trümmerteile die den weltraum
mittlerweile regelrecht vermüllen
stellen eine bedrohung für uns da sagen
forschungsteams weltweit die nasa warnt
vor einer unkontrollierbaren
kettenreaktion eine absolute katastrophe
dass kessler syndrom ausgelöst durch
einen crash werden innerhalb von stunden
ein großteil der flugkörper rund um die
erde zerstören inklusive der
internationalen raumstation iss immer
wieder schlittern wir knapp daran vorbei
es gab bereits 200 kollisionen von
satelliten im orbit der erde die ihnen
nicht auf die erde gestürzt sind und
jede produziert wieder neue schrott
teilchen inzwischen geht man von achtung
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um
die erde schwören wir sind im moment
quasi zeuge eines kessler sind roms in
zeitlupe spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009
stoßen der iridium satelliten 33 das
iridium satelliten telefonnetzes gewicht
eine halbe tonne und der russische
satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer
aufprallgeschwindigkeit und von 40.000
kilometern pro stunde bleibt von den
beiden satelliten
mehr übrig außer 100.000 schrottteilen
sie haben jetzt die chancen für den
nächsten unfall deutlich erhöhen wir
können also happy sein das sie morgens
auf die erde gestürzt ist und dort oben
keinen schaden anrichten kann der wäre
im zweifel nämlich größer als hier auf
der erde wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema weltraumschrott und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines goodie es lohnt sich also also
hier einfach draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran